quick turnaround for him ben intended he
goes swung out and missed garber's throw
got him perfect throw from mitch garber
and all the throws to first
that maybe caused a hesitation
from ben attendee and it all pays off in
a strike em out throw him out
figuring you're taking off as a runner
anticipating a breaking ball
you know maybe you're thinking that
because his go-to pitch is that
curveball you got a chance to run on
something that's gonna be below the zone
maybe in the dirt
and instead it's a high fastball perfect
pitch for garver to throw on and
nice double play right there
twins still don't have a hit but they
have two hit batters
a high fly to left field ben and tendy
going back
simmons hits his first for the twin
[Applause]
real good sign from the bottom of the
order right there was trying to get that
ball to run a little bit more underneath
simmons hands there but either way
simmons got extended on that ball and
barreled it up into the second deck it
was a real nice swing and twins have a
lead not
a good feeling heading into this game
that you really need to eat to win this
this feels like one that you need
and now a rise with a liner to right
field he's aboard
and everything hit here in the third
inning has been hit sharply
chopper toward third and out of the
glove of dozier
and the ball landing near third base
that second hop
played side saddle by dozier he got it
in the glove but couldn't squeeze it
that's a tapper up the line
and now thrown away santana didn't
handle it buxton will get an infield hit
and that ball carried off of santana's
glove and streaking in from second base
is our eyes i think you know buxton's
running but you want to make up for the
last one
and he'd probably
maybe fake this and turn around and try
and get the guy at third or whatever it
is but you're not going to throw
buckstone out on this ball
it would have been close but he's going
to be safe i mean it's a soft hit ball
with the fastest runner in the league
austin stays put it's in the dirt and
now buxton will try to advance and he
will without a throw now that's an
important play
because we've already seen keller get
one ground ball double play
and with buxton taking the extra base
that won't happen here
high fly to right field solaire coming
in the runner at third is donaldson and
he is coming home here's the throw
coming through off target
and donaldson scores on a fly ball it's
forward another
simmons hit a home run to get the twins
started this inning they've added two
more cents
a high fly left field ben and tendy
going back
and that one's gone
garber just missed a home run in the
second inning
he gets one here in the third and it is
seven to nothing
this is the type of the game the twins
wanted after a you know a tough game
yesterday uh
their game they weren't really in it and
this one he knew it immediately you see
him put his head down after he
makes contact and
good sign from the twins to be able to
bounce back after a tough loss yesterday
and really set the tone in this game and
hopefully continue this on and win the
game and win the series
i mean what's he can't do any worse
maybe they leave him in and let him try
to work through some things
and intend he has a base hit to left
field he is two for two
i mean so you wonder about the usage of
the bullpen
royals in a little string they're next
to off days monday
bubbitch is no longer throwing in the
bullpen dozier hits one to left field
deep and it is gone and now suddenly it
is
7-3 here they come without putting
pressure on yourself as a hitter you
know you know what i
i really hurt my guy i want to help him
and certainly that inside fastball
got dozier the previous at-bat but you
come in there
twice i told you they start looking in
there so they did they were he looked in
there and he barreled him
wait had the royals biggest hit
yesterday
the three run double in the fourth
inning that went
off of the second baseman polanco's
glove it was a broken bat
off the second baseman's glove three run
double
well hit left field and that will be
over jake cave
and up against the wall nikki lopez
comes around third
and it is 7-4 in the fifth inning
witt has an rbi double there's a
fastball in i'm telling you they're
going to start looking in here now it is
third time through the order
and he barreled it catch that one jake
cave no way
and again watch nikki white shoes lopez
check him out he that high hop off the
wall
liner into right center field down for a
hit headed for the gap it'll get all the
way to the wall
simmons flying around second on his way
to third and heading home
arrives with a triple and the twins
change the number
change up right here doing a good job of
just staying on this ball
kind of a mistake up and in not where he
wanted to locate that pitch but
because he's willing to use the middle
part of the field a big part of the
field he ends up getting
a hanger gets rewarded with it and a
triple
and that's the spark the twins needed to
turn the momentum back around in their
favor
drill to the left field corner arise
will score
donaldson doubled in the fourth and he's
headed there
again with a double in the sixth inning
and the twins lead grows to five
basically in the middle of the plate
here trying to get it down and away and
it had more north south movement than it
did side to side so it's one of those
things where
didn't get the pitcher he wanted to but
you know give the hitter credit he did a
nice job hitting that ball 108 miles an
hour
hit hard to center and that falls over
taylor's head
high off the wall donaldson will score
and the twins have three extra base hits
in a row
and in all four hits and three huge runs
this was fastball center cut and he
squared this thing up
just a perfect swing right there
a drive to right field and gone
he's homered at least once in all three
games of this series and that
was a tape measure shot there he tries
to challenge him in with a fastball and
he turned on this thing
and this ball was absolutely crushed
there's so much to be excited about
about this young man and
just keeps forcing his way into the
lineup
assuming they hold on here barring some
miracle but they'll be 10 and 16 we say
okay well they got to win x amount of
games in a row they don't they have to
just continue
to win series how many can they get here
glove to glove
double play started by simmons
a flip to a rise and the ball game
is over